today's show is sponsored by Simon
Cowell's owl towels made with real owls
this is the technical difficulties with
wine citation needed I have an almost
randomly selected article from
everybody's favorite reliable source of
knowledge at Wikipedia and these folks
can't see it every fact they get right
is a point and a ding and a special
prize for particular good answers which
is and today we are talking about the
Arctic winter games that's one of the
events yeah
best chuckle in a cold environment it's
probably gonna be pretty park outside
imagine you you don't know events would
be pretty quick really you need a hearty
chuckle - um you it would a hearty belly
chuckle who's he is the third sugar you
rather is it is very cold you know where
it's being hosted this year the Arctic
Arctic you meant I said Manny Jones it's
actually not in the Arctic this year is
in the amp'd Arctic no are we talking
it's not in the Arctic but on some kind
of Tecna technicality that the G rejoice
below thee yeah is it is that the old
name for the Winter Olympics and is it
in Sochi no it's not okay no not Gelbard
these are entirely different games what
could be so different that you can't
imagine this is crazy stuff like
hollowing out your own canoe walls we'll
get two games in a minute now I mean
well it's tromsø a lot real and
Fairbanks Alaska point you okay uh and
you asked who was gonna be involved in
this well a catch here is it's not for
the world
it's Inuit and other indigenous B point
zones got all the cultures around the
Arctic can someone tell me any of the
the contingents rather than countries
that are coming from all around the
world said the people that lived in
Greenland Greenland is a contingent yep
point northern Canada uh Northwest
Territories yet another point Finland
that R and R the Sami people which is in
the general area up there yep yes the
Yukons coming from Canada the yeah
Malone Annette's
from Russia that is a little it is it's
it's like I'm saying oh yes the the
Wiltshire yah Malone tenets yeah I know
them then they own most of Cheshire oh
this is the this from the yeah Malone
Annette's autonomous okrug awk are you
can't have gamelan nevets and then tip
it up with aa crocodile Krug in my Hall
so we may as well get to this then what
kind of events are being played at the
Arctic winter games aren't so I mean
there's the obvious ones yes there's
there's Alpine Skiing and there's figure
skating as ice hockey and there's at the
games do with that what are the one the
ones you wouldn't sighs its speed snow
structure building of snow bricks OB goo
um it's AG idea but no I did Tirat dog
sled racing yes dog mushing snow
snowmobile racing oh oh now that'll be
lovely there is no kind of mechanically
assisted ones in here there's biathlon
which you know you have a gun mechanicus
it's the ref Thune stone style snow burr
be called alpine skiing and I'm getting
a be greater snow erasing would look
really hose X Games the do II don't Lee
winter x-games
yeah there are a couple you wouldn't
expect him here which are very much more
elementary rocketry indoor spa squash um
badminton point
hey Gough I say elementary rocketry not
rioters Badman deal at least that's a
sport rules not a spa only eights games
yet hey sure I don't have like a double
X Games for the or triple I trip now
that I would pair to see you probably
have to yes
I'm fairly certain should any of our
viewers Google but you will in fact be
able to pay to see that
now there's one here which you're never
gonna get the name of which is called
dean games de any I may be pronouncing
that wrong it may be Zdenek and there's
no reference list anywhere on Wikipedia
so before we start I went out I had a
look at what these are and these are
traditional forms of competition of the
northern cultures okay do you want to
guess what they are because they are
interesting to say the least
are they sports they are is this where
you and it was like weird things like
toe wrestling
and old you know you're pretty dumb
cluck yeah it's that kind of thing was
that kind of it so I'm gonna give you
the - I'm gonna give you the names if
you can tell me kind of what this
involves huh stick pull he's always
holding a greased stick isn't it an
instant like that please not grease but
yes the but yeah one who ends up with
the stick win yeah for the one who drags
the other person's hand past them yeah
I'm saying I think they do that sort of
up on one of the northern Scottish Isles
as well all right because that culture
feeds in from Nordic and yes things as
well so I think I've seen that on how
about finger pull my finger well you
could I mean you know what point I see
who pulls the finger and farts loudest
series no ah is it like a game of
peanuts if you each got hold of like the
other person's one finger and yeah I
just want to scream out loser it's not
fun screaming out and give you the point
it's the first one to swell you had they
take turns defensive and offensive
it's a purpose to straighten the other
person's finger Oh and according to the
thing I'm looking at they have buckets
of ice water on hand
look there is it there is a judge who's
making sure you not doing jerking
motions it will dislocate something but
other than there's a smooth sort of yeah
whoa that sounds quite painful that hey
everybody it's like you're injured hold
Chang we need to commentate hold on
right then I can't even see because of
anything I wrap my finger out like that
Tom Scott wrapping is tom scarda going
for an offensive who's offensive who's
defensive Tom's got his offensive
wellmune up anyways he's pulling very
hard on my grave Angus actually
surprisingly difficult as well yet go
okay I'm Mac right now offensive ah oh
that's turd Matt man is better at this
game than either by easy really does
anyone want to make a comment about the
strength of my praise right hacked
anyone not me along with it
that's it here a little disappointed in
myself well everybody man we found where
you're going next it's the ice games for
you as Britain's representative in the
finger poll are you name it the goodies
champion finger polar how many how many
fates and stuff are you ever gonna open
pull my finger
as a sponsorship favor the world poll
push Google poll push a poll you do but
I'm gonna need to need more than we've
got two teams trying to hold it up or
something I'm gonna give you the point
they're gay it's basically reversed tug
of war yeah yelling you're telling drive
the other you're trying to drive the
other team past about my like a cent
amount of people II player dizzy I'm
going to see a a tug of war contest and
yelling that you're doing it wrong but
it's a way you fools
are there two more in this category one
is hand games and this is the simplest
damn thing and I can play it right now
if there is something around here here
we go I think we can literally fly hand
games right now Tom's on this wallet
bloody out which hand right hand left
there for one of us wins macro wins
point Saracen that is the hand games and
there are all sorts of regulations on
what you can and cannot do as a
distraction haha like have a live fish
in your hand yeah open it magic I want
to say that in a stadium of 80,000 per
yeah all I'm seeing is a slightly more
interesting version of watching Darren
brown Oh he'd be banned outright would
little wizard the sorcerer you don't
wanna know kind all the other kind a
coin that then disappears and reappears
in the other magician the last one is
the wonderfully titled snow snake right
it's not a cop joke Gary no I think
you'll find it is please tell me it's a
spitting cobra covered in snow no crawl
as far as you can in the snow on your
belly
you're not crawling yourself no white
I'm setting a chair you I drag someone
through the snow make it look like the
curling no you're definitely you're
getting an object to move to the snow a
snake now
Rock stick cocktails - I'm gonna let me
have stick spear all right okay yeah uh
so you've gotta glide it on the ground
so underhand spear slide sort and a far
under hand exactly right that is no
spike you stay over along hailing yeah
that's foreigner sir you have an icy
surface and you see how far you can send
your spear cool there is another set of
games so you have the Arctic winter
games you have the Winter Olympics and
then you also have the world Eskimo
Indian Olympics w e io which is held in
July or August uh-huh I wish games are
routine ancestral hunting and survival
techniques don't want to take guess on a
couple of the events ative laughs at
Bear Grylls
real-life canoe battleship wait watch
three yeah love a rock
just a big top hole and hung over the
middle of a little oh no no a little
rock ice pool or something and wronging
banging rocks over this idea oh all
right there is right no no not even
close
um there is a game called drop the bomb
is that we go
so from yeah cause on ice she would need
the grip and everything gotta go earlier
not leaving footprints and stuff they
can be traced
Oh drop the bomb no it's um a person
kind of lying face down arms out
stretches across right ah three spotters
position them part has been tightens all
the muscles muscles a spot has left the
body I'd have to carry them as far as
possible before that arms sag and they
can't hold themselves in that position
anymore huh we are trying this it does
now we also have the ear pull so I want
to take guess wait that is it something
a bit like like that it is isn't it
point not not strict that I'm two people
sitting down facing each other with
twine looped around
Oh Joseph see this
scene yeah and you pull away like that
yeah I've seen this one on the telly as
well how's that how's it working so it's
just a loop of string that hooks around
the back of your ears and you just pull
away and it says here it is stamina to
pain yeah that is all it is it's it's an
endurance competition rather than speed
or agility he's seeing they all laughed
when you got that dodgy sky subscription
to the indigenous people jawline I don't
know how I've seen all these then but
several of them I've seen you just at
one point if you got a lost week or
something at more than one wait another
that's gonna turn up of you
competing in here yes I remember any of
this
he's got all these medals were purple
he's from the south he is known as jewel
of the Sun it's um late at night around
about half 11 poach your staff for the
pubs of we would all enjoy watching men
kind of pull each other's ears off see
that's what they could do on BBC three
yeah just tour excellent and got barge
and stuff like that as well give it a
proper role in once a year I don't get
that
what cheese-rolling well it's just
running downhill in it it just Willis
down it as with achieving won't kill you
right darling down the hill with a
disease that can kill you as long as is
I already built on borrowing professor
on has got too much cheese can kill you
go mad
haha cheese can kill you if you can't
make up your tone between the EDM and
the guru you left behind your head and
for disaster cuz you didn't see the rise
too much cheese will kill you every time
oh you know I keep doing this but Gary
congratulate you in the show are you won
the freedom of the city oh no sorry you
won the freedom of the city so do enjoy
him yes no man has been migrated but i
vas been Gary Brannen that's been Chris
Joel I've been Tom Scott we'll see you
next time
that was our season finale thanks for
watching if you've liked the series then
do let us know
or better yet point your friends our way
we should be back sometime in early
autumn with another run of shows but
until then there are more than 30 audio
episodes of our reverse trivia podcast
at Tech disco UK see you soon